♪ ♪
>> Laura: FROM PORTING
DEMOCRACY AT HOME, CAN ALWAYS
COUNT ON THE AMERICAN BROUGHT TO
STAND WITH DICTATORS.
UPON FIDEL CASTRO'S DEATH,
JIMMY CARTER REMARKED THAT HE
AND ROSLYN REMEMBERED FONDLY
THERE VISITS TO HIM IN CUBA AND
HIS LOVE OF HIS COUNTRY.
OBAMA CONTINUED THAT DEMOCRATIC
TRADITION ATTENDING A BASEBALL
GAME WITH RAUL -- AND
HEALTH CARE.
IN THE MEDIA EVEN GETS IN THE
GAME.
WHO COULD FORGET BARBARA WALTERS
FAWNING 2020 INTERVIEW WITH
CASTRO?
THAT WAS CLASSIC.
SO IT SHOULD COME AS NO SURPRISE
THAT WITH THE DEMOCRATIC
PROTESTS SPELLING OUT THIS
WEEKEND, THE MEDIA, WELL, THEY
LOOK FOR A CUBAN SCAPEGOAT.
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT THE
PANDEMIC HAS MADE EVERYTHING
MUCH WORSE.
>> PEOPLE THERE ARE OUTRAGED
OVER THE COUNTRY'S CORONAVIRUS
RESPONSE.
>> THE LIFE HAS BECOME
INTOLERABLE DURING THE PANDEMIC.
>> Laura: BUT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" MIGHT'VE
HAD THE BEST REACTION WRITING
THAT THE PROTESTS WERE SHOUTING
"FREEDOM" AND OTHER
ANTIGOVERNMENT SLOGANS.
SOMETHING TELLS ME THE TIMES AS
JUST BEING HONEST ABOUT WHERE
THEY STOOD.
JOINING ME NOW, FORMER SECRETARY
OF STATE, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR,
MIKE POMPEO.
SECRETARY POMPEO, THE REACTION
FROM THE MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATS, THE LEFT, HAS BEEN, I
THINK, QUITE REVEALING TO PEOPLE
WHO FORGOTTEN THAT THEY WERE
DOING THE SAME KIND OF THING
WITH THE SOVIET UNION BACK IN
THAT '80s WHEN I WAS IN
COLLEGE.
>> YES, THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON
THE SHOW.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY THE CASE WHERE
THEY POINTED THE FINGER.
POINTED THE FINGER AT THE
AMERICAN SPIRIT THE TRUTH IS
THIS IS ABOUT COMMUNISM.
THIS IS ABOUT SOCIALISM.
THIS IS ABOUT PEOPLE DEMANDING
FREEDOM.
LIVES OF THE FAMILY WON'T BE
BETTER NEXT GENERATION FOR THEY
KNOW THAT THEIR COUNTRY WAS
DESIGNATED BY A STATE SPONSOR OF
TERROR FOR THEY KNOW THAT THINGS
AREN'T GOOD.
THE CONDITIONS OF THE EVIL
LEADERSHIP IN THE COMMUNIST
DICTATES HAVE SWILLED THEIR
LIVES AND THEY WANT FREEDOM.
WE SEEM TO BE ADVICE AND
AMERICAN FLAGS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND.
IF USING ANYBODY DOWN IN FLORIDA
WHO LEFT CUBA, THOSE EXILES THAT
ARE NOW LIVING IN AMERICA, THEY
KNOW FREEDOM, THEY KNOW THE
ROUTE OF IT, THEY KNOW THE
BENEFITS OF IT, THEY KNOW WHY IT
MATTERS TO THEY SOLD THEIR
POCKETBOOK.
ALL THE PEOPLE ARE ASKING FOR.
IT IS ABOUT THE CORONAVIRUS,
THIS IS NOT ABOUT AN AMERICAN
PLOT PAID THIS IS THE CUBAN
PEOPLE FUNNEL AND --
>> Laura: THEY DID NOT THE
SAME THING DID THEY NOT DURING
THE HONG KONG PROTEST.
THERE IS A VERY NEEDED REACTION
BY THE ELITES HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE POINTED OUT WITH THE SPORTS
COMMUNITY WAS DOING.
WHICH WAS SUPPORTING REAL
SUPPORT OF WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN
KONG KONG.
THAT IS A HUGE ISSUE THERE.
THIS IS NOT REALLY SURPRISING,
IS IT, TO ANYONE WHO HAS SEEN
WHAT THEY'VE DONE OVER THE
YEARS?
>> NOT AT ALL.
IT IS THE CASE OF THE LEFT IS
ALWAYS COAX --
ALWAYS PLAYED FOOTSIE WITH THEM.
HAVE NOT SEEN THE EVIL THAT IS
PERPETRATED BY THEM.
THEY SLUMP IT OPERATES ON
POSITIVE AND GOOD SO FAR AS TO
SAY BOY THAT SYSTEM WORKS PRETTY
GOOD TRADE THIS IS WHAT THEY
SAID ABOUT THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY.
WOW, THE HEAD OF COVID REALLY
WELL.
WE KNOW IT COMMUNISM DOES TWO
COUNTRIES.
WE KNOW WHAT IT DOES TO THE
SOULS OF PEOPLE AND DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THAT'S DEMOCRATS
ARE SILENT ON THIS TODAY.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE CUBAN PEOPLE, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO STAND
ALONGSIDE THEM.
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS WE CAN
DO.
WOW TO HELP THEM GAIN THIS VERY
FREEDOM THAT THEY ARE OUT IN THE
STREETS DEMANDING.
WE NEED TO BE WITH THE CUBAN
PEOPLE PRAYED THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAD THE RIGHT END
OF THE STAKE.
WE PUT ENORMOUS PRESSURE ON THE
CUBAN LEADERSHIP.
I HOPE THE BIDEN TEAM ONCE
RELEASE THE PRESSURE THAT WE HAD
ON THE CUBAN LEADERSHIP.
THAT PRESSURE PLUS THE FREEDOM
DEMANDS OF THESE PEOPLE IS
LIKELY TO LEAD TO A VERY GOOD
OUTCOME FOR CUBA AND I WAS A
RESULT OUTCOME FOR THE SECURITY
OF AMERICA AS WELL.
>> Laura: IS NOT THE CASE THAT
THIS ADMINISTRATION THINKS THAT
CONSERVATIVES IN THE
UNITED STATES WHO WAVE THE
AMERICAN FLAG AND NOT ON
MEMORIAL DAY OR FOURTH OF JULY
AND FLIGHT ALL THE TIME OR
HEAVEN FORBID VOTE OR SOMETHING.
THEY ARE THE BIGGEST THREAT TO
THE UNITED STATES.
THEY ARE DOMESTIC TERRORISTS
WERE APPROACHING -- MUCH BIGGER
THREAT THAN A COMMUNIST
DICTATORSHIP IN CUBA OR MAYBE
EVEN CHINA.
AT THIS POINT.
LOOK AT THE EFFORTS THEY ARE
PUTTING INTO JANUARY 6TH.
IF THE LAND THEY PUT THAT EFFORT
INTO CHANGING THINGS IN CUBA.
SPEAK OF THE IRONY THERE IS THAT
THEY OFTEN SAY THAT --
THEY ARE THE TEAM THAT LOVE
HUMAN RIGHTS AND YET WE SEE THE
HUMAN RIGHTS THAT ARE BEING
VIOLATED THEIR AND WE KNOW THESE
SAME PEOPLE WOULD LOVE NOTHING
MORE THAN TO COME TO THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, THE
SAME PLACE THAT THESE DEMOCRATS
ARE DENIGRATING.
THE VERY FLAGS THAT THEY ARE
DENIGRATING IS THE VERY FLAG
THAT THE CUBAN PEOPLE SO
DESPERATELY WANT TO HAVE ON
THEIR SIDE.
IT SHOULDN'T ESCAPE US, THIS
HYPOCRISY.
IT IS DANGEROUS WHEN THE
DEMOCRATS UNDERMINE OUR
REPUBLIC.
WE CAN DO BETTER.
I'M CONFIDENT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE CAN SEE THAT.
AND IF WE GET THIS RIGHT, WE'LL
IMPROVE THE RIGHTS OF PEOPLE ALL
ACROSS